Wade Smiths welcome to the forge
gentlemen I know that cloth draped items
in the middle of this Forge make you
nervous so let's make you feel more
comfortable
[Music]
what you see here is a fairbane Sykes
fighting knife this iconic knife is the
deadly melee weapon of British Commandos
dating back to World War II designed by
William ewert fairbane and Eric Anthony
Sykes the Sleep knife was often employed
in silent and surprise attacks on
enemies and had the ability to quickly
penetrate deep into vital areas of the
body
now
what pray tell are we going to forge
these blades out of
foreign
these are rounds of W1 Steel in varying
diameters your challenge is to take
three different diameters of W1 steel
and Forge weld them together into a
Billet from which you will make your FS
fighting knife good luck blade Smith's
your three hour starts now my name is
Richard Cruz I love origin knives it's
like playing with Play-Doh when you as a
kid you can mold it to be many things
but it has to go through the fire him
bands are the same way we have to go
through fires in life to be molded into
what we need to be it I'm bringing it up
to heat now got to get those Wells set
good to be able to turn it up and square
that Billet back up so I'm going to keep
my heat up and get my well set good and
then Square my building
I believe I got my well set I believe
they're all rock solid and I'm going to
shape my point you know my general
profile out shaping this thing up and
you get one side right and you look over
on the other side and you went too far
so you got to go back to match those
sides up I mean that symmetry is crucial
to correct function
I'm about to quench everything's looking
straight and good
I've got my blade hardened and I'm real
comfortable with it it looks good
my name is Elijah Williams I am really
blessed to be able to be a full-time
blade Smith and a stay-at-home dad the
hardest part is finding the time to
dedicate specifically to that as a job
you're like okay I'm done with the
diaper changes I got to go make a knife
now I'm going to take some of the
smaller pieces and start flattening the
three separate pieces out until they're
relatively the same thickness
I'm heating my steel up to welding
temperature it's with flux on it I'm
doing a weld pass with a hammer and
repeating the process I just want to
make sure that weld is good before I
move on I'm getting really worried about
Elijah
I see flux heat Hammer brush flux heat
Hammer brush and he's just not making
any progress these welts should already
be set that's set now they're not going
to be
the forge weld is finally good and I'm
forging it out into roughly the shape
that it needs to be at least now it
looks like he's trusting as well the
shape of this knife is designed for
penetration and because of that it's got
some very gradual tapers to the blade
just hoping to get this blade heat
treated and back on the grinder so I can
get these bevels finished up before the
clock Runs Out
Elijah has uh has quenched
it's got a little bit of a warp to it
I'm bending it really really carefully I
think I've got the warp out of the blade
it's not perfect but I can't spend any
more time on it I gotta clean these
bubbles up a little more get my edge
geometry down and and make this blade as
nice as I can
my name is Austin Hensley I'm from
Roswell New Mexico I am a firefighter
EMT As A Firefighter I do deal with a
lot of stress and a lot of pressure you
know there are people's lives are on the
line I can't choke up I feel like
that'll help me here in this competition
I'm gonna go with the three biggest
diameters that they got out there so I
have enough steel Austin he cut up three
discs stacked them weld them like a
wedding cake salt W1 it's simple steel
to forge well together and then throw
your blade out from there quick and easy
my little wedding cake paid off it's
been pretty good I think I got one solid
piece it makes me feel happy
I've got my blade profile I'm gonna try
and set it for round two it looks like
he's gonna thread that Tang already
we're gonna make a through tang and
might as well make it to thread it on
through Tang make it a real strong
construction now the fs fighting knife
weighs less than half a pound and that's
why the heat treat is going to be so
crucial don't overheat it don't
underheat it get it just right get that
nice fine grain structure
this thing quenches his blade I've got a
hardened blade I've got my threaded
through Tang I'm feeling pretty good
up your tools this first round of
smithing competition is over
bladesmiths congratulations you've made
it to the second round of this
competition and now that those blades
have been tempered it's time to turn
them into fully functioning fairbane
Sykes fighting knives good luck your two
hour Starts Now
I've got to make a slotted cut in this
handle right down next to the blade
because I've left the Tang wider almost
like it's keyed at the top right so you
can key the Tang at the top and keep the
rest of the Tang round right and just
worry about slotting the top of that
lock into place on top
a good idea
got us all three it's welded on just a
little bit crooked I don't see that I
have time to correct this it's just
going to have a little ugly hole at the
bottom of it
sliding my handle on there and it's not
going all the way up to the guard I'm
gonna have to force it
kind of tapping things together at the
tip of the blades dripping down into the
wood of his workstation there oh that's
not good
let's hope that tip's strong
hey man
captain
so the guard on this Fairborn Sykes
combat blade it's there to keep your
hand from slipping onto the blade when
you're stabbing your target so I need to
make it big enough that it actually
works for what it's supposed to do and
then make it as close to the original
knife as possible
Pummel on this knife is not large it
doesn't need to be and all it's there
for is to hold the handle on securely
and provide a striking surface if needed
Elijah going to weld onto the mall for
it does he have the guard on it now is
that guard going to fit over that old
thread you brush it
[Music]
I forgot to slip my guard on over the
Tang before I welded that thread on
there and now it doesn't fit the only
thing I can do is cut off the all thread
put my guard on and weld it back on so
with precious minutes wasted that was
great move
I made the pommel out of the bronze and
now it's time to slide my handle
material upon and attach them to Blade
I noticed things are moving that aren't
supposed to be moving I look at that nut
that I put on there the threads broke so
I over timed it as far as getting this
handle attached these threads are make
or break this is a big problem that's
what's holding everything on there
that well is going to stick to that nut
to the tank and it's not going to move
anywhere stem through these Jerry cans
isn't just going to test the blade it's
going to test the entire handle
construction so I don't want to be sent
home because my pump will falls off it
looks like Austin's sharpening with a
half an hour to go I really like to see
him work on that handle that handle is
pretty fast
for the gas can stab I'm grinding my
Edge accordingly I want my tip to have
you know some meat to it but also I
wanted to go through it
I think Austin's handle is going to be
way heavier than it needs to be but it's
hard to get into underneath that guard
and taper that down
that's all I can do to it five
four three
two
one blade Smiths this second round of
competition is over
welcome to the strength test Our Guest
can stab
I'm going to take each of your daggers
and try to sabotage these enemy gas cans
it's going to test the overall
construction of your knife as well as
your heat treat Richie at first how you
feeling be sweet Jay
[Applause]
good job Richie your blade held up good
you lost just a hair of the tip
your handle is out of alignment from the
blade a little bit so a couple of those
stabs when I went down it kind of
torqued a bit but got no chips no rolls
everything's strong good job thank you
thank you
okay Elijah after seeing that how you
feel a little nervous but
it is what it is
foreign
good job you still have an edge
everything's still tight overall nicely
done thank you
and then there was one
how you doing I'm doing pretty good
let's see if your knife does the same
thing
oh
all right Austin we obviously have a
problem here yeah the heat treat it was
an issue you could probably see from
there your brain structure it's very
coarse the other thing working against
you was the weight of this handle having
this much weight coming in behind this
Blade with a brittle heat treat on it we
just lost it
Austin your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in the middle of
our strength test for that reason we
have to ask you to please leave the
forge
I'm not ashamed of what I did here today
I overcame a lot of challenges and it's
not going to stop me I'm just going to
keep growing
this has taught me that you know never
stop learning always push for better